Yeah, yeah.
So what is it?
This is rosemary.
Oh.
Rosemary.
After finishing grad
school at the U of A,
University Distinguished
Outreach Faculty Dan McDonald
decided southern
Arizona was home.
I think I was led
here first of all
by the influence
of my parents, who
were very community-minded
people in the small town
that I grew up
in, in New Jersey.
My father was a
volunteer fireman.
My mother was one of the
crossing guards in town
and very engaged
in the community,
a member of the
recreation commission,
and that type of thing.
Turning university research
into relevant programs
for the community,
McDonald and his colleagues
provide resources
to learn and explore
the benefits of gardening,
nutrition, and a generally
healthier lifestyle.
What I love about
my job in Extension
is my ability to connect people.
So I see myself as somewhat of
a convener, of a relationship
builder.
And so I try to
keep tabs on what's
going on in the community,
where the needs are,
and who's doing what--
and within the
universities as well.
You could say Renaissance
man, in some sense.
He has a broad view of the
world and, in this case,
of children and
health-related ideas
that he brings to the table.
That's new.
And he's also a real
feeling sort of guy.
He has an appreciation
for the bigger picture.
We're not in the classroom
in a traditional sense.
So our classroom
is the community.
One classroom is
the garden kitchen,
located in a former
Mexican food restaurant set
to become a clubhouse for the
local chapter of the Hell's
Angels.
No problem with
the Hell's Angels,
but the neighbors there
decided that that's not what
they wanted in their community.
They really wanted something
to address some of the health
issues in South Tucson.
So I approached the county
and said, I have programming,
you have a building, we
need a teaching facility.
What do you say we go
together jointly and do this?
In the five years
since, the kitchen
has served over a quarter
million people in Pima County.
So we have a program with
high school students called
Healthy Living Ambassadors.
Part of that is
for those students
to be trained to deliver
nutrition and physical activity
lessons within their schools
and in their community.
A culminating event
that we have for that
is hiking the Grand Canyon.
So we take about 60
high school students
to hike the Grand
Canyon in the spring.
Part of that, they're learning
how to deliver information
to others.
But they're also incorporating
that into their own lives.
And it really
motivates younger kids
to see other teenagers
that are my age
and see that we're hearing
about healthy living and things
like that.
And it makes them want
to be involved, too.
An enthusiastic sing-along
guitar and ukulele player,
you might find him at
the Tucson Village Farm,
singing about the perils
of canning your own food.
He's also a long-time
distance runner.
So that's what I find really
exciting about being part
of the University of
Arizona, is that it's just
such a tremendous resource
to the community here
in Pima County, but then
throughout the state, really.
Because there are programs
all over the state that then
I'm able to make sure
where the need is,
that there's a need being met.